en este vídeo veremos la estéreo química
de una reacción sn uno del lado
izquierdo tenemos el alumno de alquilo o
también llamado halogenuro de alquilo y
del lado derecho tenemos a nuestro
núcleo filo con una carga negativa en el
azufre y sabemos que el primer paso del
mecanismo s en eeuu no es la pérdida del
grupo saliente entonces si estos
electrones se van con el bromo se forma
el anión bromuro y como le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono de color rojo
entonces el carbono rojo ahora tendrá
una carga formal positiva dibujemos eso
el carbono de color rojo corresponde a
este carbono entonces este carbono tiene
una carga formal positiva y en el
siguiente paso de nuestro mecanismo
ocurre el ataque núcleo físico verdad
entonces el núcleo fi lo ataca al
electro filo y se forma un enlace entre
el azufre y el carbono de color rojo
pero recuerden que la geometría
directamente alrededor del carbono rojo
es decir los carbonos que están unidos a
ese carbono como este carbono rosa este
carbono y este carbono de color rosa se
encuentran en el mismo plano que el
carbono rojo así que el núcleo filo
puede atacar por cualquier lado del
plano en este punto creo que nos
ayudaría mucho usar un modelo molecular
aquí les tengo una captura de pantalla
del vídeo que les mostraré en un momento
en este vídeo he puesto el bromo de
color verde
entonces la esfera verde es el bromo y
este grupo metilo que está hacia
nosotros será de color rojo del lado
derecho tenemos este grupo de ti lo que
será la esfera de color amarillo y
finalmente del lado izquierdo el propi
lo será gris aquí tenemos el alumno de
alquiló con el bromo lejos de nosotros
el grupo metilo hacia nosotros el grupo
de tilo a la derecha y el propio a la
izquierda
entonces giraré esto un poco para tener
otro punto de vista sabemos que el
primer paso es la pérdida del grupo
saliente entonces estos electrones se
van junto con el bromo y se forma un
carbó catión pero así no es como se ve
el carbó catión necesitamos tener una
geometría plana alrededor del carbono
central por eso aquí les tengo otro
modelo que se ve más preciso ahora el
núcleo filo puede atacar por la
izquierda o por la derecha primero
veamos qué pasa cuando el núcleo filo
ataca por el lado izquierdo aquí
formamos un enlace entre el azufre y el
carbono y les voy a enseñar el modelo
molecular de uno de los productos este
es el producto que se forma cuando el
núcleo filo ataca del lado izquierdo del
carbó catión aquí está otra vez nuestro
cargo catión y esta vez supongamos que
el núcleo filo ataca por el lado derecho
así se forma un enlace entre este azufre
y este carbono entonces hagamos el
modelo del producto
se forma cuando el núcleo filo ataca del
lado derecho este es el producto y aquí
tengo el carb ocasión para que los
podamos comparar ok ahora comparemos
este producto con el producto que se
forma cuando el núcleo filo ataca del
lado izquierdo en mi mano izquierda
tengo el producto que se forma cuando el
núcleo filo ataca del lado izquierdo y
en mi derecha tengo el que se forma
cuando el núcleo filo ataca del lado
derecho entonces cuál es la relación que
existe entre los dos bueno los dos son
una imagen especular del otro pero si
trato de sobreponer los si pongo uno
sobre el otro podemos ver que no se
puede por lo tanto son imágenes
especulares no superponibles son
enantiómero ahora veamos nuestros
productos desde otro punto de vista
tomaré el producto de la izquierda y voy
a girarlo para que ahora el sh quede
hacia nosotros aquí tenemos el grupo sh
hacia nosotros
el grupo metilo lejos de nosotros
a la derecha y el pro pilot a la
izquierda y si ahora observamos el otro
producto aquí podemos ver que el metilo
está hacia nosotros
el grupo s h lejos de nosotros el estilo
hacia la derecha y el propi lo sigue
hacia la izquierda aquí tenemos los dos
productos que vimos en el vídeo pero
como no siempre tenemos un modelo
molecular a la mano regresemos a los
dibujos que tenemos aquí y supongamos
que no tenemos un modelo molecular
sabemos que el núcleo filo ataca al
electro filo y que se forma un enlace
entre el azufre y el carbono entonces
vamos a dibujar nuestra cadena de
carbonos y sabemos que se forma un
enlace entre el azufre y el carbono
vamos a resaltar los electrones
supongamos que el par de electrones de
color rosa de este azufre forma este
enlace y este es nuestro producto pero
si analizamos nuestro producto observen
que este carbono es un centro quiral
grupos diferentes unidos a ese carbono
entonces si pensamos en la estéreo
química de este mecanismo con el núcleo
filo acercándose al electro filo por los
dos lados del plano como producto
debemos de obtener una mezcla de
enantiómero entonces si dibujamos
nuestra cadena de carbonos por aquí
podemos representar un enantiómero al
poner el grupo sh con una cuña aquí
tenemos nuestro sh y esto significa que
el grupo metilo debe de estar lejos de
nosotros
y dibujamos el otro enantiómero ahora el
grupo sh se encuentra lejos de nosotros
por lo que el grupo metilo ahora se
encuentra hacia nosotros y observen que
estos dos productos coinciden con los
modelos moleculares que dibujamos aquí y
como existe la misma probabilidad de que
el núcleo filo ataque de un lado o del
otro
podemos decir que esperamos obtener una
mezcla equitativa de productos entonces
voy a decir que aproximadamente el 50
por ciento corresponde a este
enantiómero y aproximadamente el otro
50% de nuestros productos corresponde a
este enantiómero ok y finalmente veamos
los estados de hibridación de este
carbono de color rojo en el alumno de
alquilo inicial el carbono rojo tiene
una geometría te trae drica tiene una
hibridación sp3 por eso tiene esta
geometría y cuando formamos nuestro
carbó catión el carbono rojo
ahora tiene una hibridación sp2 tiene
una geometría plana pero cuando se
forman nuestros productos regresamos a
un carbono con hibridación sp3 y
geometría te trae drica por eso es
importante pensar en la este kiómetro